[Music]
russia has invaded ukraine and the world
is watching
but why has russia done this can the war
be stopped who will help the many
thousands of people fleeing the fighting
and what can we do to help
in a special edition of your week the
new show we've been investigating the
ukraine invasion
over the years we've reported on many
wars on fyi it's a sad fact that
conflict has been part of the human
world for as long as we've been around
but seeing a european country like
ukraine being invaded is a first for
many of us isn't it yeah and we get just
as upset as you when we see violence and
suffering no matter where it is in the
world
so we're on a mission to explain
everything and look at what is being
done to find a peaceful solution
yeah so i guess one of the biggest
questions about any war really is why
and it can be complicated it can be
super complicated so we've been
investigating why russia would do this
[Music]
to truly understand why ukraine has been
invaded by russia we need to hit the
history books and go back inside
[Music]
from 1917 when the royal russian family
were overthrown
until 1991
we saw the rise and the fall of the
soviet union or the ussr ukraine was one
of the 15 states that made up this giant
country
all of them became independent countries
when the soviet union's political system
and economy collapsed in 1991 and its
people demanded change russia was the
country with the biggest power
surrounded by smaller states as you can
see here
russia's current president vladimir
putin came to power in 2000
he has always made it clear that the end
of the soviet union angers him and some
world leaders believe he would like
russia to become a huge empire similar
to how the soviet union used to be back
in the day
and he wants to claim back some of the
former soviet states
in 2008 russia invaded neighbouring
georgia and took control of a large part
of the country
it's very much like what he's doing with
ukraine now
trying to take back a former state that
largely wants to be independent of
russian control
2014 is a good year to look at the
relationship between ukraine and russia
the then president of ukraine with a
close relationship to russia faced huge
protests demanding he quit and when he
did russia's vladimir putin thought that
ukraine was about to become more
friendly with western countries like the
uk and the usa
so he sent in russian soldiers to take
control of crimea which is an area in
the south of ukraine
let's travel in time right up to the
present day the ukraine invasion is now
a very complicated situation
rebels are people who go against the
government in power
in february russia sent in its troops to
support a rebel army from two other
regions who also wanted to be
independent from ukraine lehansk and
danesque
so rebels with russians began fighting
against the ukrainian army
but the most important thing to know is
that this was just the start of a
full-scale invasion of ukraine
president putin appeared on russian tv
to want other countries not to try and
stop them
there is huge support for ukraine here
in the west for all his bombs and tanks
and missiles
i don't believe that the russian
dictator will ever subdue the national
feeling of the ukrainians
and their passionate belief that their
country should be free just like other
former soviet union states the ukraine
is an independent country wants to join
the military alliance nato
and the european union
but the russian president is demanding
ukraine doesn't join them
there are still large russian
communities in many former soviet states
including ukraine
while some would like to be part of
russia world leaders say president putin
has no right to weighed in
and many say this invasion is illegal
and russia will be punished
one thing you can be sure about is that
the world has been watching events in
ukraine very closely and those in power
are doing all they can to bring about a
peaceful solution and i've been looking
into how the world is reacting
[Music]
for weeks many world leaders and senior
politicians tried to convince russia's
president putin that an invasion of
ukraine was not what ukrainians wanted
or even his own people and that it would
be viewed as illegal and russia would be
punished
but he sent his forces across the
ukrainian border and began an unprovoked
attack on the country bombing military
targets in key cities including the
capital kiev
so what happens
next the many families taking shelter in
underground stations and bunkers from
the gunfire and explosions know the
world is watching and reacting
[Music]
military action by other countries has
been ruled out that could lead to a much
bigger war
instead european countries including the
uk are providing the ukrainian military
with supplies and weapons
no one really knows why but the russian
advance in the early days of the
invasion has been slow the ukrainian
army is fighting back hard led by their
president vladimir zelensky
he urged russians not to listen to their
president
we need to stop this war
we can live in peace together globally
as humans
world leaders including the uk prime
minister have described the invasion as
a pointless war and they're punishing
the russian president with financial
penalties called sanctions which means
they can't do business outside russia
and won't be able to access money or
property abroad
russian airlines are banned from flying
across or landing in europe
this is all to try and cut russia off
from the outside world to stop its
actions
the world of sport has also stepped in
the football governing bodies uefa and
fifa have suspended russia from
competitions and many other sporting
events due to be held in russia have
also been cancelled russia has also been
banned from this year's eurovision song
contest
many ukrainians are staying put in the
country instead of fleeing the invasion
we've got a video diary from miroslava
who lives in kelmanitsky she is among
loads of teenagers who have stayed
behind to provide food and aid to
refugees as they make their way through
the country to the border
right here people are making nuts which
serve as
a masking equipment for our military
so right here the food has been
collected
and
over there our volunteers are working
and collecting
some other stuff
and medicament
for our soldiers i've never seen so many
volunteers in one place
miroslava joins us now
hi maurice lava thank you for joining us
hi guys thank you for making this
program and for speaking to me
why have you not fled ukraine why are
you staying behind to help those who are
where i am now we have several uh air
raid sirens per day and people have to
spend
some part of the day hiding in the
underground shelters the situation is
relatively safer than in kim or
in hakeev but still we are helping
people who are coming to khmer natsuki
as
refugees we are also sending the
humanitarian aid to the front line and
it's it's truly horrible to see our
mothers with their toddlers coming to
manlinski only
with one back
with their documents
with no extra worm clothes and we are
trying to provide them on the food
and
we are hosting them in our own homes in
schools
sports centers cinemas and even in
churches but it's scary to
to think that uh tomorrow you may become
one of those refugees too
well thank you so much for speaking to
us and i really hope you stay safe i
want to thank you and thank all of our
foreign friends for supporting us and i
want to ask you to continue supporting
us
we've been told by refugee charities
that an estimated 4 to 7 million people
are expected to flee the fighting
already hundreds of thousands of
refugees are crossing the border into
neighbouring countries that's moldova
romania hungary slovakia and poland
refugee charities are warning that there
could be a humanitarian crisis if those
countries don't get the support they
need to take care of ukraine's refugees
the good news is that the european union
has announced that all ukrainian
refugees will be allowed to stay in safe
countries like poland for up to three
years
the first thing you notice is that it is
mainly women and children crossing over
the border into neighboring countries
that is because the ukrainian government
has asked men to stay behind and fight
katarina who is 18 had her brother 12
year old vadim have just arrived in
poland
they told fyi their parents like many
others have stayed behind to help fight
the invasion they stay
there to defend our country they want it
for us to come there and
now we are here it's really bad
so i must say that
[Music]
we have really warm in our country
children
can't do nothing so
i um
really beg uh adults to protest in such
way in
anything
uh to stop this world to stop this
really
bad thing in our country
we were so worried about katarina and
vadham that we've kept in touch with
them and they told fyi that they've now
reached friends of the family in
slovakia
all the refugees are being offered
shelter by local families in their homes
and temporary accommodation in halls and
schools
they get there by car train or on fort
there are so many refugees some are
waiting 30 hours to cross
anna alabed knows what it takes to
travel hundreds of miles to reach safety
she's a refugee from syria where a civil
war broke out between government and
anti-government troops forcing millions
of people to flee
she became well known for her tweets as
her city was bombed by her own
government and its supporter russia
banner's family escaped to neighboring
turkey banner has been posted again
about her concern for ukrainian refugees
and she's joining us now hi banner
hi so it must be so tough for you to see
yet another refugee crisis do you think
that they will get the help they need i
i think they will get the help they need
if the world all focuses on one goal and
that is to bring peace and to stop these
words because every child deserves to
live in peace and
leaving your whole country because of
war is really tough because you need to
find a new home you need to find a new
school you need to find a new friend and
that is really tough and i really hope
that
everybody will fix this thing and the
war will stop and
the people will go back to their
homelands and live in peace thank you so
much banner
countries around the world are sending
money food and water to help refugees
including the uk
many of us are wanting to do what we can
to help donating whatever we can to
collection centres across the country
thomas has more on this from london i'm
here at the pogus centre in lewisham in
london this is one of the drop-off
points that has been set up across the
country to help ukrainian refugees as
you can see it is extremely busy with
boxes being put into trucks
so why did you volunteer today because
ukraine
needs help people may be starving
they've been walking
country to country every day
it's really hectic here there are so
many people and so many donations some
of this being kids cloves food nappies
sanitary products and that's just a few
of them we have been packing all the
stuff that people have been donating and
putting it in trucks by going to poland
have you got the truck coming keep
packing keep packing
we've been here for a few hours
everyone's been working flat out and
there's already another truck here for
loading
while more trucks like these packed full
of aid we'll keep heading to border
countries of ukraine as long as we keep
donating whatever we can back to you
guys
thanks thomas now i suppose it's the
least we can do as we watch these events
unfold in ukraine and watching the news
can be scary sometimes can't it so we
invited members of fyi school news clubs
to send their questions and worries into
fyi's counsellor anna
is it okay to feel scared about what's
happening in ukraine even though i'm not
there
so if you are feeling any worrying
feelings or feeling scared you really
aren't on your own okay it's because we
feel empathy and sympathy for those
people that are caught up in all of this
conflict so yeah if you are feeling sad
or upset it is very very normal but
don't sit with those feelings okay make
sure you talk to someone particularly an
adult that you trust share that emotion
don't just be sat with it
i feel really anxious i'm worried about
the war and what it might mean for us
could this lead to another world war
it's natural to be worried about what
will happen next and be careful as well
on what new sites you're accessing don't
keep scrolling through unreliable
sources that are perhaps scam mongering
or dishing out incorrect information
only go to reputable news sites in order
to get the correct news and what is
actually happening when you do you'll
realize that world leaders are doing
everything they need to do to avoid this
war getting worse and affecting more
countries you can turn that concern as
well into doing something for charity do
something proactive like sending
donations to a collection center for
refugees just like thomas has just seen
people from all countries all around the
world have come together to protest
against russia's invasion of ukraine
including russia itself which is brave
because protests aren't allowed there we
leave you with pictures of a world
united in shock but also in hope for
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you